in the tough world of chicago pd and
nbc's greater one chicago universe it
can be good to have a friend you can
count on
officer alvin olinsky stakeout and
undercover expert of the cpd
intelligence unit
is loyal to a fault both to family and
to his old partner hank voigt
this loyalty does not transfer to the
code of conduct or moral standards of
the force
like voight olinsky is not afraid to get
his hands dirty in the name of enacting
either justice
or revenge on someone who has wronged
him being hard to recognize is part of
the point of being undercover
but it doesn't have to be the case for
the actor who plays olinsky
elias kotius has worked as a character
actor in film and television for decades
here are a few specific films and tv
shows where you may have seen him before
one chicago isn't codius's first
experience with a gritty urban
multimedia franchise
to a certain audience the man will
always be legendary for his portrayal of
casey jones
in the 1990 live-action teenage mutant
ninja turtles movie
well that was a crime you purse
scrubbing pukes
and this is uh the penalty
codeus gives some much-needed definition
to jones's dim-witted stereotype
he realizes that no one would fight
purse snatchers and gangs of ninjas with
a baseball bat
if he wasn't having a lot of fun doing
it he treats all of his fellow heroes as
peers
be they human or turtle or giant rat and
he balances out jones's meathead
tendencies with surprising but
natural moments of intelligence codius
would return for teenage mutant ninja
turtles 3
playing both jones and wit a character
who helps the turtles when they travel
back to
feudal japan in 1998 codius was cast in
the role of captain james staros
in terrence malik's poignant war drama
the thin red line
captain staros is a man who's arguably
too good for war
he cares too much the deeply religious
company commander has been with his men
throughout training
and the war and the responsibility he
feels for their safety
has come to outgrow his sense of duty to
the mission or his superiors
so when he's ordered to make a frontal
attack on a heavily defended japanese
bunker during the campaign to retake
guadalcanal
he refuses arguing that he won't send
his men on a suicide mission
codius performance as the quietly
tortured leader drew special
commendation from reviewers and variety
and positive notes from roger ebert it
was selected by indie wire as one of the
best performances ever given in a malik
film
that's not the only time cody has proved
to be a secret weapon for a celebrated
auteur
he had a small part in martin scorsese's
2010 psychological mystery
shutter island as andrew laudis an
arsonist who investigator teddy daniels
believes killed daniel's wife
and whose presence on the island
supposedly lures daniels into taking the
case
that sparks the film's mystery codius as
lattice is striking
with a still red gash held together by
staples that runs from one temple across
the bridge of his nose
and down nearly to his cheek he also has
one cloudy eye
and his teeth are capped with silver
he's sitting in an armchair in front of
a roaring fire
striking matches to keep himself company
even in this hallucinatory dreamscape
that the film conjures
this scene stands out it's a performance
that's dissonant with everything the
viewers know about him
and with his own appearance the same
year that elias codius played a
nightmarish vision of a name for
scorsese
he also starred as a prosaic police
detective for matt reeves and his
youthful vampire romance
let me in throughout the film the
policeman as he's known
slowly unravels the truth behind a
series of murders in los alamos new
mexico
circa 1983. the evidence seems to point
to them being ritual killings
which given the blood drainings and
strange mutilations
is not an unreasonable assumption but
it's still the wrong one
the truth is that the killer he's been
searching for the young girl he
eventually realizes is at the heart of
his case
is a vampire that revelation leads the
film toward its bloody conclusion
regardless of the role codius has a
knack for infusing his characters with
gravitas and a world-wary experience
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one